when I heard this I almost fell off my
chair this gentleman Who I Really my
trainer yes
we're talking about how much we gave at
the wedding we're in the back office and
I say Mike what did you give for the
wedding oh I gave him 50 bucks
he should have wiped his ass with a card
written you and put it in the box
like that is so offensive Steve were you
offended by trainer's 50 gift for the
wedding yeah I just thought it was hot
everybody was so generous and like we're
going through gifts and it's like 50
bucks I'm like is that like a typo or
something like it was just so and then
like I'm in the airport going to my
honeymoon we're getting this beautiful
honeymoon in Mexico and I'm sitting in
the airport going why did Mike give me
fifty dollars listen I I love Steve and
I gave him a very small amount I admit
that I did give another fifty dollars so
you've got a hundred for me he felt so
guilty he goes wait hold on hold on he
gets on the website and very quickly
sends 50 more like coming in increments
I'm gonna pay you an installment a
layaway I just feel like that is such a
resentful gift my wife said to me she's
like did you talk to Mike trainer like
did you like say something I'm like no
no I wouldn't say she's like he sent
another fifty dollars
foreign